plus plus de restaurants ni de sport en
club s'en passe sanitaires pour les plus
de 12 ans depuis ce matin le
gouvernement qui veut par ailleurs
prolongé se passe pour tous quasiment un
an nom parle tout de suite avec à notre
reporter david khalifa devant le
ministère de la santé bonsoir david
alors les parents ne sont pas forcément
pour se passe exigé pour les mineures
mais ils ne sont pas les seuls à s'y
opposer david
effectivement à stéphanie il est gibles
depuis le mois de juin les adolescents
de 12 à 17 ans ont obtenu un sursis de
deux mois ils doivent maintenant montrer
patte blanche lui aussi comme pour les
adultes dans les mêmes endroits que les
adultes en tout cas les bars les
restaurants les bibliothèques les
théâtres les cinémas bien encore les
piscines alors beaucoup estiment que
c'est la seule solution pour retrouver
une vie normale mais d'autres sont
beaucoup plus réfractaires à cette idée
écouter
alors moi je suis pas pour que ça soit
obligatoire mais je pense que c'est
quand même une bonne chose parce que on
sait que les jeunes en contamine mais ça
ne touche pas en contamine plus les plus
vieux donc je pense que c'est une bonne
chose pour eux pour l'école au lycée on
sait que au lycée on saute à 1000
beaucoup donc je suis plutôt favorable à
ça alors malgré que je sais que c'est la
seule sortie pour cette crise c'est
quand même un peu un peu agaçant pour
par exemple les plus jeunes ceux de 12
ans 13 ans qui sort encore avec leurs
parents et que leurs parents peut être
coincé par par leurs enfants qui n'ont
pas encore pas sanitaires ou autre chose
après c'est la seule c'est la seule
solution donc on est obligé en fait date
d'accord parce que c'est l'état qui a
décidé voilà c'est comme ça c'est une
aberration sont jeunes en pleine santé
il n'y a aucune raison nécessité de
mettre un vaccin à des enfants qui sont
en pleine santé qui sont censés
développer le système unitaire et des
eaux plutôt que de toute façon ils
veulent pas qu'ils aient de vie normale
et puis on ne peut pas avoir de vie
normale dans ces conditions c'est pas
une vie de devoir présenter un passeport
rentrée pour l'ached hamburger ou sinon
c'est au point jeunes c'est pas non plus
une vie enfin on qu'on a jamais connu ça
disons que c'est plus une prison armes à
ciel ouvert quoi donc c'est que ces
libérations j'avoue j'ai pas tellement
suivi le fil d'actualités des
différentes parce sanitaire je suis même
pas vaccinés ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose que je cautionne bien que
je comprenne il est d'une vaccination
maintenant pour les 12 17 ans j'ai cru
comprendre qu'effectivement c'était
quand même un terrain assez important de
propagation du virus donc fait
mensuellement si la faction de la
vaccination de mener obligatoire ça me
pose un cadre de plus de problèmes mais
le passé militaire ça laisse aussi la
possibilité d'un pc air derrière donc
pourquoi pas un test pcr qui deviendra
payant à partir de la mi-octobre et
c'est là aussi que ça peut poser
problème pour les jeunes qui refusent de
se faire vacciner qui n'ont pas
forcément les moyens de payer un test
pcr alors ça concerne environ 5 millions
de personnes en france selon elle les
données du ministère de la santé 71 %
des 12 17 ans ont déjà reçu au moins une
injection soit à 3 millions à 600 milles
adolescents 1500000 elle reste à
vacciner les conséquences économiques
elles sont
et elles et elles vont affecter de
nombreux secteurs notamment les bars et
les restaurants car de nombreux jeunes à
la sortie d'élite du lycée se
rassemblent se réunissent dans des cafés
ou des bars et pour les gérants et bien
c'est encore plus compliqué à gérer ça
ajoute une certaine contrainte et pour
eux mécaniquement égard il va y avoir
une baisse de la clientèle c'est la
crainte première des professionnels qui
imaginent que les jeunes non vaccinés ne
souhaite plus revenir dans les bars ou
dans les restaurants les clubs sportifs
également sont touchés ils subissent
cette nouvelle mesure beaucoup ne
souhaitent plus pratiqué de sport
collectif s'il faut présenter un test
négatif ou un schéma vaccinal complet et
david exécutif qui réfléchit également
une prorogation de ce pass and i ter
jusqu'à l'été prochain et donc après la
présidentielle des annonces de gabriella
talent qui font beaucoup réagir
évidemment
oui le pass sanitaire qui devait
s'arrêter au 15 novembre pourrait
finalement être exigée jusqu'à l'été
2022 c'est en tout cas le souhait de
l'exécutif
à en croire les mots du porte-parole du
gouvernement
un avant-projet de loi a même été
transmis au conseil d'état qui va
remettre un avis au gouvernement ce qui
forcément interroge du côté de
l'opposition sur le timing mais aussi
sur la fiabilité et de l'exécutif
florian philippot le chef de file des
patriotes sur twitter rappelle collier
vert en avait affirmé que le pass annie
terre ne serait pas prolongé au-delà du
15 novembre le 25 juillet est dernier et
accusent le gouvernement de menteur le
sénateur républicain à la houppe air se
demande lui aussi où sont les limites à
du pouvoir quant au sénateur bruno
retailleau l et es présidentielle sont
problématiques le sénat ne pourra pas
autorisé le gouvernement à prolonger se
passait sanitaire vous l'aurez compris
les débats au sein de l'assemblée tout
comme au sénat risque d'être houleux
merci david kelly fin pour ces
précisions